[Music]
oh we're not gonna need those
hello albert i'm detective sergeant
baxter i know who you are
this is a scene between denzel
washington's character rami malik's
character
and my character albert sparma there's
this
interesting power dynamic that's going
on between
the established kind of uh
veteran detective the the the new kid on
the block
and the potential suspect
you're famous on television and the
papers all the time thank you so much
i'm kind of a crime buff
well then you know if you're innocent
you should talk to me clear your name
there was no rehearsal of the scene the
entire scene was spontaneous
is that it
you're not gonna work me over to prepare
for that scene you gotta have an
understanding
about the reality that your character
lives in the circumstances john lee
hancock left the decision up to me
to decide about albert sparma's guilt or
innocence which was
really quite interesting because it gave
me kind of a a bit of a tight rope
to balance on i invoke my fifth
amendment right against
self-incrimination
just kidding i really enjoy the
preparation i really enjoy the research
i enjoy diving deep i love when it's
physical
as well as emotional and
the interrogation seem was a chance to
see
really to introduce albert sparma and
his
his bizarre wit and sense of humor
you should see the look on your faces
come on it's hilarious
but i would like my right sway record i
know i'm not officially in custody but
better be safe than sorry huh guys
hot down as an outsider as someone who
really doesn't quite fit in to society
i think he feels quite at home in that
interrogation
can i keep this you know he's someone
who's quite used to
using humor as a tool both in his
attempt to keep people off balance to
get people to reveal things
and um to keep them guessing um
it was the first scene between the three
of us and
it was electric where did you abandon
your car albert
harvester what's good for hauling things
around
look jimmy detective back because i said
the car was stolen
thank you for finding it i'll drive it
home and we'll be hanging onto it for a
few minutes that's not very nice of you
why didn't you report the theft
well you see that's the funny thing
i did somebody's got some homework to do
it was a blast for me because it's the
type of character that
you just can't say the wrong thing you
know he's a bit of a square peg in a
round hole
uh and he he often will
say what's right on the front of his
mind
um without any filter or censor
and that was pretty compelling um and i
have to say an extra special thank you
to
rami malek for putting up with the
avalanche of
of ad-libs and improvisation that
uh that i brought with with uh albert
sparma it was kind of just part of this
surprise
is part of the you know it's part of the
the character um
cute little thing wasn't she you said
she's
i know the drill jimmy the truth is i'm
not the guy
besides if you had anything anything at
all
i'd be in her arrest when i
do you want to be i wouldn't mind
getting a peek at all that evidence you
say
god
you get the feeling he's enjoying this
oh yeah pineapple's in our penis please
i think it's fair to say that albert
would weaponize
his sense of humor
but certainly it was a way for him to
keep
the detectives off balance
for a way for a way for him to exert his
power
and his dominance in the room
uh and to savor the moment as well he
he really you know it's like a big meal
that's in front of him and
you know he's there to enjoy every
single
potato skin 11 more you can make a
calendar
oh hey stranger
tired of steaming up that glass
prezzies oh yeah
[Music]
is is the part where i start feeling
like it's trap open it up by now
it's not a pair of mittens
come on take a look you know you want to
[Music]
[Music]
holy guacamole robert sparma was a
head-to-toe
transformation which i really enjoyed uh
and we did a lot of experimentation with
um the physicality meaning
money no catch a dead girl by her dog
[Music]
the conscious is all off
it's no ouija huh
my god you know i i remember every
moment
of that that day from denzel's
walk across the set to rami's
entrance with this clipboard it was just
explosive
for me personally you know denzel
washington is one of my
heroes he's one of the greats and i was
so grateful to have that opportunity
with him let me ask you a question
why is that huh
why is that there was quite a bit of
improvisation
right from the get-go and
i think it's what the scene needed come
on you're smart man you
know every exit on the highway
let me help you
i mean why
it wasn't about the dialogue and the
page going away but it was really about
taking the cues from john lee's
beautiful writing
and going somewhere with it why not
hey it's all right it's all right we
know
you know we got you by the balls small
as they are
you son of a [ __ ] you know it's control
i'm so grateful personally for
the gift that rami and denzel and john
lee
gave me which is the faith that they had
in me the confidence that they had in me
um
because it was quite you know
intimidating to be
in that chair with those two uh
and also exciting and i just tried to uh
focus on the excitement
and you know i put on a diaper and uh
just strapped in for the day
you